in this video i'm going to show you the
specific way that you can use the five
second rule to stop doubting yourself
and worrying so much now a lot of people
will tell you oh
just think positive or meh try not to
worry
it sounds simple but it's not easy and
the reason why it's not easy is because
it doesn't work and actually research
shows that when you try to ignore your
worries it can actually make them worse
look i understand this topic more than
most people because i struggled for
decades not only with worrying and
self-doubt i actually suffered from
anxiety and panic attacks for almost 25
years and in fact i took zoloft for two
decades to control my anxiety
using the five-second rule i've not only
been able to stop worrying and doubting
myself i've cured myself of anxiety and
i've been off meds for more than four
years i'm panic attack free and i almost
never ever worrying about anything and
you can teach yourself to do the exact
same thing using the rule
first here's what i want you to know
you're not a worrier
a lot of us call ourselves a worrier
right oh i'm a warrior you're not a
worrier you have a habit of worrying
that's a very big difference
you've allowed your mind to drift and
linger on negative thoughts so many
times it's now a pattern of behavior
that you repeat and you don't even
realize it and that's actually good news
because that means that you and i can
use the science of habits to break the
habit of worrying and the habit of
doubting yourself
in the language of habit research the
five-second rule is what psychologists
call a starting ritual
it's it's a tool that you can use that
will interrupt the negative thought
patterns that are encoded in your brain
as habits
and trigger positive new thought and
behavior patterns the five second rule
is shockingly effective because it works
with all the latest research about
habits what i've learned using the five
second rule is that i do in fact have
control over what i think and when you
use the five second rule you'll discover
that you do too here's how you're going
to use the rule the moment
the moment that you feel your thoughts
drift and you ever noticed how worrying
and self-doubt they have a way of
literally like
taking you away from a situation you can
feel your mind go from the present
moment to drifting to something negative
maybe you're sitting at a meeting at
work and
suddenly you start talking down at
yourself and doubting yourself it
happens like that but the moment that
you catch yourself do it that's a moment
of tremendous power you have a decision
to make you can either sit there and
listen to the worry and listen to the
self-doubt and let it hijack you or
you can make a decision to assert
control
that's when you use the rule
you're going to use the countdown trick
54321
it's essential counting backwards
interrupts the negative thought pattern
it's also going to awaken your
prefrontal cortex which is the part of
the brain that you need to override a
bad habit and replace your bad habit
with a positive new one so every time
you feel your thoughts drift to
something negative or you find yourself
worrying about things you can't control
54321 it'll switch the gears in your
brain it'll interrupt the negative
thought pattern it'll activate your
prefrontal cortex and you've just
created a starting ritual
that will prime your mind to accept a
more positive thought
that is how you use the rule to change
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how you
can conquer your inner self-doubt
enjoy
rule number two focus on taking action
so we got a cool question on twitter
from langley in nigeria and it has to do
with something that we've been hearing
from a lot of you about and that is
impostor syndrome particularly for those
of you that are running a small business
or those of you that have a side hustle
that you're trying to turn into your
full-time thing impostor syndrome is
very real let's deal with it right now
langley writes from nigeria i'm
passionate about film and cinema mel i
tweet and i blog about it people are
inspired by what i write but when i'm
offered certain opportunities i clench
up and suddenly feel like an imposter
who will mess up and be found i'm 36 i'm
single in a paycheck to paycheck
situation and feel like i have wasted
many years due to overthinking
self-doubt and never feeling good enough
or ready how can i overcome this well
you can't you can't overcome the
feelings that are rising up langley but
you can take action despite them that's
a very important distinction that i want
each and every one of you to understand
the things that you're feeling clenching
up feeling like you're not good enough
feeling like you're not ready doubting
yourself kind of spending too much time
thinking about how much time you've
wasted all that that's normal that we
all do you cannot overcome those
thoughts because they keep rising up and
they've become a habit and it's sort of
a pattern so i don't want you to focus
on the thoughts i want you to focus on
taking action even though you doubt
yourself you are going to feel like an
imposter until you push through that
clenched up moment over and over and
over again and then suddenly through
action langley you're gonna see that
you're not an imposter at all you're
actually the kind of person
that pushes through
and does what he or she says they are
going to do see impostor syndrome grows
and sticks around when you listen to it
and when you keep thinking and when you
freeze the moment you take action even
though you feel like an imposter you
actually explode the syndrome you kill
it you break it apart because you're not
acting like an imposter you're proving
to yourself
through the action
that you
know what you're doing now look the
feelings are going to take a while to
catch up the first
16 jobs that you do
where you feel nervous
those nerves are going to be there with
you the entire time feeling nervous is
normal letting it stop you is a choice i
say this stuff all the time because this
is what you're struggling with if you
suffer from imposter syndrome it's not
an issue of whether or not you have the
skill the problem is that you have a
pattern of thinking in a way that stops
you the moment you start to doubt
yourself if you want to be successful in
business if you truly want that side
hustle to turn into your full-time thing
you have to learn how to let the
feelings
of doubt rise up but take action anyway
you've got to learn to embrace the fact
that you're gonna feel like an imposter
but you my friend are the kind of person
that moves forward anyway you're
passionate about film and cinema awesome
keep tweeting keep blogging when people
write to you when they hire you and you
get that
clenched up feeling that's a great sign
it means you're about to do something
really cool that's when you're going to
just recognize the feeling
54321 take action like the rock star
film and cinema guy that you are i hope
that that helps but the only thing
that's going to help you with imposter
syndrome is for you to not listen to it
and take action anyway rule number three
improve your mindset now what i want to
do is i want to talk to you about the
three strategies that will keep you the
secrets to building an optimistic
mindset you ready excellent here we go
um number one the secret to an
optimistic mindset you gotta be maniacal
about your intake
negativity in here means negativity in
your body gets stored here and
negativity comes out here
it becomes this loop of negativity and
so in order to build a positive mindset
i want you to be maniacal about positive
input that means
really watch your news intake do not be
watching it every day get the facts
get what you need to know from a trusted
measured
calm
factual source
and then turn that [ __ ] off okay that's
number one number two edit your social
media
anything on your social media feeds
should be
helping you be more resilient
more optimistic
more um
positive
anything
that you're following that triggers you
that is negative that rubs you the wrong
way you know one of the things that i've
noticed
i have some favorite celebrities that i
have um followed for a while because i
think they're funny or i love
um just kind of their sense of humor
but there are so many people that i have
muted right now because i think that
what they're doing online is so freaking
out of whack
seeing people give us advice about
quarantining from the back of their
estates and mansions telling us to
donate when they're not saying they're
donating
seeing this kind of tone-deaf
celebrity thing going on i'm normally
not a negative person about that but i
have muted muted muted so many accounts
because it's not doing anything for me
and you got to be selfish right now you
have got to edit your social media feeds
so that your social media feeds are
helping you build an optimistic and
positive mindset and so every day the
second i see some mute mute mute mute
unfollow unfollow unfollow because
negativity in means negativity gets
stored here but negativity goes out
there from you you want to put
positivity optimism tools strategies
things that keep you laughing keep
things that keep you giving you things
that you can use right now
the second you start getting overloaded
with corona stuff mute that stuff edit
edit edit your social media based on
what you need that's number one maniacal
about your intake the second secret to
building an optimistic mindset is
do
tiny things every day that boost your
mood okay
so we're gonna build your mood muscle
if you can move your body
because negativity gets stored here and
moving your body we know based on the
research simply moving your body for 10
or 20 minutes a day will release
chemicals in your mind
that help you boost your mood the second
thing that will boost your mood is i
want you to make a tiny promise to
yourself every day just one thing that
makes you feel more positive is it
getting up on time
is it eating something healthy
is it only having one glass of wine or
reaching for a mocktail i want you to
put one tiny promise into place put it
into the
um comments right now what's one tiny
promise that you can make to yourself
that you're going to do every day it
might just be that you're going to wake
up every day take a deep breath remind
yourself that you're healthy and that's
going to be the tiny promise i want you
to do one tiny promise every day because
keeping a promise
to yourself will boost your mood and
make you feel more in control another
way to build your mood muscle is
have a zero tolerance policy for your
own negative thoughts
right now as you edit social media and
edit your news take and edit your
negativity coming in from the outside
world
do not tolerate negativity from the
inside world the five second rule is
genius for this count backwards the
second that negative 54321
not listening to it no i am redirecting
my thoughts that's right i am looking
for the things i can control i am
keeping a positive attitude by focusing
on things that i can control right now
today got it good the third thing that
you need to do in order to build a
optimistic mindset you ready everybody
here we go
i want you
to pick a small
10-week goal
that you can
control
why am i saying 10 weeks i'm going to
tell you why 10 weeks because i think
that we've got 10 weeks ahead of us
of physical distancing
i think we've got 10 weeks ahead of us
if we do it right of life in this
weird state
and i want you to pick one thing
one project that's it
for the next 10 weeks that's your
personal project it's something you can
control you ready
something you can control we're talking
about how to build the skill of an
optimistic mindset and part of an
optimistic mindset is focusing on what
you can control
and i don't want you to jump ahead
and worry about what's coming in the
future i want you to stay in this moment
with me
i want you to realize that if you took
on one small project for the next 10
weeks that you can control
something you've wanted to learn some
skill that you would love to have some
deficiency in your resume or your
experience that you could gain in the
next 10 weeks if you narrow your span of
control
to managing
your mood
to being maniacal about
the intake into your mind
and working on a 10-week goal
you will be building an optimistic
mindset
because you will have weeded out
negativity in from the outside world
which means negativity won't get stored
here and it won't get expressed from you
you will have built your mood muscle by
forcing yourself to move every day
by keeping a tiny promise to yourself
and by
being
absolutely zero tolerance for your own
negative [ __ ] on the inside 54321
redirect your mind to something you can
control
and having a 10 week personal project
where you pick something and you use
youtube university
and you use this moment of time
where you don't have anywhere to go and
you don't have social distractions you
got time to focus on yourself
these three things will help you build
an optimistic mindset
absolutely positively
guaranteed rule number four make a
decision i think we're all flawed and
that's the beauty of who you are
and instead of trying to make yourself
perfect in every area it's so much
easier when you accept the things that
you're terrible are at or that are your
weaknesses or that are the things about
your wiring look if i were diabetic i
would take insulin
i happen to be somebody that's wired for
anxiety no big deal
so figure out how to
instead of fighting those things
actually
trick it
because the truth is that you're never
gonna feel
ready to make these changes you're never
gonna feel like doing them but you can
always make a decision that's always in
your control
staying with somebody that treats you
like garbage is a decision
it is
staying at a job that you hate is a
decision
staying in the body
that you are not proud of is a decision
is it going to be easy
no it's not going to be easy to change
it's simple
[Music]
do a google search and then use the five
second rule to force yourself to do that
stuff
change comes down to five second
decisions and this is why the five
second rule is is important for
everybody to know
it's your job to push yourself
and i don't care if you're dr martin
luther king jr or your michelangelo or
your lin-manuel miranda who wrote
hamilton you will struggle with
self-doubt
and everybody that you admire everybody
and the list is the same prairie oh
oprah winfrey and i want to be like you
know tom and i want to be like uh you
know
branson and i want to be like jay-z and
i want like everybody's listeners bill
gates and do you know what those people
do
they do not have the habit of hesitating
they trust themselves also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five build motivation
you see what you need right now
is you need to start building the
motivation of your mind because
motivation doesn't exist in your body it
comes from up here
and what i hear is that you now have an
opportunity this is what the test is
peter to train harder because you are
capable of so much more
this is handing you a moment
where you get to become an even stronger
and more capable version of yourself now
does that mean that you're going to be
motivated
all day long
every single day that you wake up no
but it means you've got to have the
mental fitness right now to continue to
get up
to show up
and to dig deeper when it comes to your
mindset when it comes to your attitude
when it comes to your
just knowing
that you are going to get through this
and so this moment everybody it's
telling you who you are
it's telling you whether or not you're
the kind of person that shows up to a
challenge and you're pissed off
or you're sad or you
feel depressed or you feel despair or
you feel all of these things that start
to take you
down the drain of negativity and what
i'm here to tell you is that you are
built for this moment you may not feel
like it you may feel sad those are all
normal feelings you may feel negative
it's very easy to do you may start to
feel a little bit of despair that's
going to come and go but this is where
the test of this race that we're
currently running lies
when those feelings rise up and you
start losing ground and you start
feeling like you're not going to make it
to the finish line and you start feeling
unmotivated can you dig deeper and
remind yourself that you were built for
this moment
because one of the things that i know is
that when the [ __ ] is hitting the fan i
guarantee you there are people in your
life that are looking to you
there are people in your life whether
it's clients or colleagues or family
members that are looking to you right
now you know what that tells me that
you're the kind of person that people
rely on
and now is the moment in time in the
race that we're all running
where you got to teach yourself to rely
on yourself
how do you do that how do you build the
muscle of the mind
it's very simple
very simple i didn't say easy i said
simple the steps are very simple
to win
this race
and to build strength in this muscle
right up here
you gotta focus
on the [ __ ] you can control
and that is what you do with your body
and what you do with your mind
and the one thing that has made a huge
difference in me because you can see
that i am showing up as a very different
mel robbins than i've been the last
couple weeks the last couple weeks i
have been losing the race i've been
going up and down i've been doing my
best to stay positive
but i am now back in the race i have now
found my ground and found my footing and
it comes in focusing on what you can
control and you know what you can
control there's only one thing
it's what are you doing to make this day
the best day that you can do what are
you doing to master this day today
tomorrow
forget about next week forget about
what's happening this summer
this is a race that will be won
by those of you
who are the ability to focus on today
and making today amazing and so you know
what i did today
today i did something i haven't done
since the beginning of this quarantine i
got up an hour earlier than i normally
do why well because i noticed that
throughout my day i was feeling behind
throughout my day even though i was
waking up even though i have a morning
routine even though i was getting stuff
done
i felt
even
though i was doing all those things
somehow behind and i realized that in
order to master my day in order to be
fully in control of what i'm going to do
today
i got to make sure that when my ass hits
this chair at 9am and my workday starts
i have fully taken control of everything
that puts my body and my mind first
and when i was honest with myself
about why i was losing ground and why i
wasn't feeling motivated and why i was
starting to feel
my own energy cycle down
it was because i was not taking the time
in the morning to give myself the mental
prep and training and the physical prep
and training so that i could make this
day today april 14th with everything
that i got
and so that's what you need to do rule
number six use the high five habit the
high five habit is no different okay so
i find myself uh last year at a very low
moment i am standing in my bathroom it's
a moment i know every woman can relate
to
they're in my underwear
uh i'm looking in the mirror
and of course i am picking myself apart
i'm like i hate how i'm getting really
jowly right here
and i don't like how i've got these like
big lines that are starting and then i
notice you know i've got this like
indent right here that i don't like and
i don't like these like kind of marks
right here that go this way on my neck
i've covered this foundation
and then this boob hangs lower than the
other boob and i'm just picking myself
apart because that's what i've been
doing for the past four decades that's
what almost all women and even men do it
too this is what i'm finding based on
the research of the book and then as
soon as my mind is negative about my
appearance my mind goes negative about
my day
oh god i forgot to text lisa back i
need to finish up that report oh my gosh
my first zoom meetings and not oh the
dog needs to be walked and now i'm going
down the road
negative about the day
the whole vibe is
and i don't know what came over me
but i
just
literally had nothing to say to myself
i really felt overwhelmed just an
average low moment
and i found myself as pathetic as it
sounds raising my hand and high-fiving
my own reflection in the mirror
braless in my underwear
it felt good
i put my shoulders back i felt a little
bit like okay i got this and i went on
with my day the next day
there i am again
and my mind is going negative and i'm
like nope high five
and that's what the high five habit is
but this is just the beginning the the
high five habit book is full of a
bazillion tools but i want to unpack
this one
because there's so much science here and
for women in particular
this is
unbelievable
in how it changes you and your
relationship with yourself
so first let's start with a high five
when like think about when in your life
you have either given or received high
fives
what does a high five from someone else
or a high five that you're giving to
somebody else communicate um you're on
the same team you're like in it together
yeah yeah and you know it's also like i
think about it you like give it to
somebody before a big play we got this
you give it to somebody when their
attitude's going down come on keep going
pick your attitude up you give it to
somebody in celebration and so a high
five communicates support and
empowerment and partnership and trust
and celebration
and it's so powerful and we're so good
at giving all of those things to other
people like you and everybody especially
women we cheer for our friends we create
birthday parties we buy people presents
we do work for our colleagues when
they're overwhelmed we help our parents
out with whatever we're so good at
cheering for our favorite musicians and
buying people's stuff
we are horrendous
at giving that same support and
celebration to ourselves in fact we not
only don't give ourselves support and
celebration we do the opposite we tear
ourselves down
and we beat ourselves up and we pick
ourselves apart
and every single woman i know
is constantly saying how the do i put
myself first
how do i do how do i love myself i know
i'm supposed to
well i'll tell you how you do it
you put yourself first by
doing for yourself what you've been
doing for everybody else because that's
how everybody else became first in your
life
you need to start to cheer for support
and validate yourself
period
i realize now that i'm high-fiving
myself
that i have spent
the first 40 years of my life either
criticizing my reflection or ignoring it
how sad is that
it's incredibly heartbreaking and yet
it's extremely familiar to me
yeah and i think a lot of women yeah
and believe it or not a lot of men
there's a lot of men that don't want to
look themselves in the eye in a mirror
and be with themselves because they're
so focused on the things that they
haven't achieved
or the things that they've failed at
and so they're ignoring themselves
they're not being with themselves
and so first things first when you
take a moment in the morning to just
stand in front of the mirror and be with
yourself
and then you raise your hand in a
gesture that you have always associated
with celebration support belief
and empowerment with other people
there's a number of things that happen
that um can be proven by research first
things first uh this is research out of
harvard it's recent
uh they've shown in studies that simply
taking a minute in the morning to get
intentional about who you're going to be
today and how you're going to show up
changes your productivity it changes
your level of confidence it changes how
impactful you are as a leader at work
and in life
so this moment in the mirror is not to
be diminished this is a moment for you
to be able to take a moment and
intentionally align yourself with who
you're going to be
second piece of research is from a field
of study called neurobics
it basically means when you marry a
physical action
with something a thought that's
unexpected
you accelerate the development of new
neural pathways
and there's famous studies that have
proven that if you brush with like your
non-dominant hand while you're thinking
something it sticks in your mind because
you have to focus
well the same is true when you raise
your hand
and high five your own reflection you
see you've been doing this for your
entire lifetime so there's already
subconscious programming here lisa the
second that you raise your hand like
this
it is so programmed in your mind to
associate belief cheering empowerment
celebration you know with the high five
itself
that
it's impossible to go god i hate my neck
boy is that cellulite ugly you can't do
it because this part of the mind
immediately takes over and does all the
positive stuff with a high five it's
crazy try it tomorrow morning you will
not be able to criticize yourself
now there's another piece of research
around this which is you know when you
do a high five we did one the first one
we did right we didn't quite hit each
other in the right like
good smack so what did we do we did it
correct because a good high five
requires you to be present
and intentional
isn't that cool yeah oh
high five
and so what i started to notice was that
i was in real time
shifting
my relationship to myself
instead of criticizing the woman i saw
in the mirror or ignoring her i was
developing a partnership
a trust
a sense of self-validation a i have my
own back i see you mel robbins we're
going to have a great day today we got
this no matter what it is that life is
going to throw at us you got this
that's how it all started and then of
course i put it on my story after a
couple weeks of doing it and people
around the world started to post them
pictures of themselves doing it and then
all of their stories started rolling in
about the difference that it was making
there was one woman that
said that she's been struggling with
this body dysmorphia for 20 years
cannot look in the mirror and after five
days of doing this
can stare at herself in the eyes
with a grin
five days five
days
and the reason why
is because of the lifetime association
that you have
with doing this for other people
so when you try this tomorrow here's
what i want um you to do
stand in front of your bathroom mirror
and take a moment and just be with
yourself for a second and then if
there's resistance to raising your hand
and high fiving your own reflection
what is that resistance rule number
seven control the gap the question is
how do you deal with the anxiety that
comes from waking up and being on a roll
and realizing
that
when you're
making things happen it's easy to look
back and realize how much of your life
you wasted and that makes you present to
how potentially little time you have
left and how much there is to do
in the little time that you have i
can so
relate to this so relate to this the the
few things i want to say about this is
that i don't think that our experience
of feeling anxiety about getting it all
done before your life is over getting it
all done and the time that you have
i don't think it's unique i think that
that is something that starts to happen
when you feel like your life is on a
roll
and you're not present to misery but
you're actually present to
power
and joy
and all the cool possible things that
you could do does the anxiety or how do
you make the anxiety go away i don't
think you can i think that that is a
very normal thing to feel
when you're a big thinker and you become
present to the fact that when you put in
the work and when you focus you really
are capable of creating just about
whatever you want in your life
and that's both empowering
and daunting and terrifying as hell and
so you can't get away from that anxiety
but you can respond to the trigger i
often feel what you're talking about
when i'm on an airplane and maybe it's
because i really i feel very vulnerable
and out of control when i get on a plane
and i click the buckle
and i realize this puppy could go down
and then i think about okay i spent 49
years here
there's so much more i wanted to do so i
can relate to this so there's two things
to this one is being present to time
passing and the fact that we're all
gonna die and that your life is a
[ __ ] gift
when you get present to that that's the
biggest motivator on the planet and when
you
feel one of those moments
what i do is i shrink it down and i try
to find something in this moment that
i'm incredibly grateful for so that if
it were to end right now
then
all would be well i think about the
sunset i'm looking at i find a picture
of my kids and my husband i think about
you know the lives that have been
touched by the five second rule and that
gratitude in the moment allows my mind
to not go psycho thinking about
the big vastness around life and those
big topics so that calms me down
immediately that's number one number two
i think a slightly different question
than um
it's probably anxiety but i think it has
more to do with momentum and how
when you start to get unstuck and you
start to see things happening
you'll notice
that things feel like they start moving
faster as if you are on a treadmill and
somebody has secretly come up and turned
it up on you
and
there are days where we're moving
through our day
like this morning was one of them we're
getting ready for this live training and
all of a sudden i caught myself almost
about ready to hyperventilate because i
wasn't present to this i was present to
sh what happens when we have a thousand
people show up and where are we gonna
you know you kind of speed it up on
yourself
so when that happens i
know that i'm in the future
54321 i need to be right here and right
now and that
when you
start having big things happen and when
you start feeling unstuck and when
things start moving the momentum you
know because an object in motion tends
to stay in motion your anxiety will make
it roll faster that will not make you
effective you have to slow it down
immediately just in the case of getting
overwhelmed by the big themes in life
when you start to feel like things are
going too fast oh my god oh my god i
don't have enough time i'm gonna have to
no yes you do
slow it down
okay you know i'm always looking for new
ways to explain the power of the
five-second rule and the power of
five-second decisions and i read
something that tim ferriss said that
really resonated with me and he
had this one line buried in a podcast
somewhere that just jumped out and it's
it's it's stuck and what he said is he
said something about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you
and your response and your entire life
is that gap when you start to
this is not what he said he i kind of
identified this gap and i of course
intrinsically was like well
absolutely that's the five second window
between instinct or stimulus and your
reaction and when you start to
understand that your whole life plays
out in this five second gap and that
there's a gap that's five seconds long
between
fear and courage and there's a gap
that's five seconds long between
self-doubt and confidence that is your
life and what's super cool about
understanding that your whole life is
inside this gap is it's so small
everybody that you have the ability to
control it life's always gonna throw
triggers at you and there will always be
all kinds of cool things that inspire
you your wisdom and you get to choose
what happens in that gap do you succumb
to an excuse or do you push yourself
forward when you start to speak up in
business you'll be shocked at how you
start to speak up and your relationships
when you start to make hard phone calls
whether it's in a selling situation
you'll be surprised at how you'll start
to close the gap and have hard
conversations
in your personal life and so that gap is
everywhere and it's the same everywhere
and when you start to go to work in
controlling how you live in that gap
between stimulus or idea and your
response that's where the magic is and
that's what you're experiencing rule
number eight end procrastination we all
procrastinate we avoid the things that
we know that we need to do and then we
spend the rest of the day beating
ourselves up it's amazing
actually it sucks doesn't it so how do
you stop procrastinating oh
simple just nail yourself to a chair
that's what you do you tell yourself no
booze until you get it done that works
oh it doesn't the reason why these
things don't work is because most of us
don't even understand what
procrastination is
i know i certainly didn't
the reason why you procrastinate is not
why you think
procrastination has nothing to do with
work
procrastination
is a stress reliever that's right it's a
tool that you use to give yourself
relief from stress that you feel the
stress that you may be feeling right now
might be stressed about money you might
be stressed about your health maybe
you're stressed about something going on
at work or about a relationship that
you're in
and the way that this relates to
procrastination is
you're stressed out you got work you
know you need to do but instead of doing
it you go online or you watch the
highlights of last night's game or you
waste an hour looking at facebook and
when you do that when you avoid work
makes you feel good but just for a
minute
see this is where we get procrastination
all wrong a lot of people think
procrastination
is about willpower it means that you're
lazy has nothing to do with that it's
all about your stress that's why your
work ethic or discipline that's not
that's not gonna solve this either
the key to stopping procrastination
number one is understanding what it is
it's a way that you deal with stress and
number two
it's about five second decisions that
stop the cycle of procrastinating
because when you change your decisions
you're gonna change everything and
here's how you're gonna use the
five-second rule to do it
when you catch yourself procrastinating
or you feel yourself starting to avoid
what you need to do
use the rule
54321 activate your prefrontal cortex
and then acknowledge acknowledge that
you feel stressed out that's the first
piece
then you're gonna use the five second
rule to just get started that's it for
five minutes that's all i'm asking
force yourself i'm stressed out i get it
but i'm gonna work for five minutes five
four three two one sit down and get
started
after you've worked for five minutes
give yourself a break watch all the cat
videos you want i don't really care
the point here is that this is a way
that you can use the five second rule in
combination with research about beating
procrastination that puts you in control
of your decisions
stacy found that when she used the
five-second rule to improve her
relationship with herself
there was an amazing result she stopped
procrastinating in her words your rule
has helped me grow in ways i never
thought possible i no longer
procrastinate on anything and the same
is going to be true for you because when
you understand that procrastination is
something that you do when you're
stressed and you also understand that
the secret to beating procrastination
which is a habit
is to just get started
now you can use the five-second rule to
leverage all the research that will help
you end the habit of procrastinating
once and for all rule number nine infuse
your days with celebration i
believe
with all of my heart and being
that every man woman child person
grandparent everybody
should
infuse their days with habits of
celebration and self-confidence
and the fastest and easiest and most
science-backed way
to
quickly start to change how you see
yourself
is by adopting a simple habit of
high-fiving your reflection in the
mirror every single morning
now i know exactly what you're thinking
are you serious mel robbins that is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
entire life
i know
i know i know it sounds dumb
but the reason why your first instinct
when you think about waking up whether
you're in your robe or your underwear or
your pjs or your birthday suit and
walking into that bathroom and having a
moment with yourself and raising your
hand and high-fiving yourself
is because your self-confidence is in
the gutter
you believe some garbage about yourself
you think you're a bad person or you're
unworthy or you're ugly or nobody likes
you or how about this one this was the
story of my life i have [ __ ] up my
life so badly
i might as well just flush it down the
toilet
you have some narrative in your mind
that is so negative that when you look
in the mirror you see somebody worth
trashing
you see what's wrong you pick apart your
appearance and i want to reverse that
because here's the deal about
self-confidence
self-confidence
begins with you
you
realize the word self is in there right
i can't give you confidence i can give
you a little boost i can give you tools
i can
encourage you
but confidence is forged in fire
it's something that's within you
and here's the thing i want you to
realize about confidence
you are a confident person
that's why you miss feeling that way you
can only miss what you know you've just
been blocked from the feeling of it
and wherever you are right now in your
life i'm telling you confidence is in
there you just gotta figure out how to
tap into it and you've been building
confidence all along by the way
every time that you have fallen on your
face or you've tried something and
failed or you've gone out and thought
you found the love of your life and then
your heart's broken and then you pick
yourself up again and then you dust
yourself you're building confidence the
entire time because confidence is not
built on the high days confidence is
built on the low ones confidence is
built when you are struggling because
when you see yourself go for something
and fall when you see yourself try and
get knocked down when you see yourself
stand back up after getting abused or
traumatized or discriminated against and
moving ahead you are building
this reserve within yourself where you
know you can rely on yourself you know
you can face hard things and you can
keep moving forward you know you have
your own back so it's in there your life
has been helping you build it now you've
got to just dig in and tap into it and
use it to shut that critic up in your
head so the way you're going to do that
is every morning i'm not kidding you're
going to raise your hand in the mirror
and high-five yourself look at how many
people are doing this
you're not the only one for five
mornings in a row i want you to
high-five yourself
and when you do this i want you to use
the hashtag
high5 challenge you know what's
happening when you raise your hand up in
the mirror
you are taking the lifetime positive
association that you have with cheering
for other people believing in other
people
uh celebrating other people
saying let's go to other people
and you are marrying that positive
association
with your reflection it is impossible to
raise your hand in the mirror and go i
suck you can't do it
because your brain and the subconscious
sees this and thinks let's go i love you
i believe in you and when you do this
every single morning something
incredible happens first of all you're
not going to leave your bathroom feeling
like you're dragging a boulder you're
going to leave there feeling like the
winds at your back
secondly you're going to have spent the
morning the first thing in the morning
by taking a moment and being with
yourself
and not seeing your face and picking
yourself apart but actually seeing the
person
that's underneath the skin the soul
that's behind the face you are going to
shut the critic up you're going to
silence your to-do list and when you
raise your hand like this it also
prompts you to think about the game
you're playing so now you've got a
moment to be like oh yeah yeah me i'm
still here
i can make today a good day in fact what
game do i want to play today just for me
so that's the first thing that you're
gonna do you're gonna high five yourself
take the high five challenge which is
high five yourself five days in a row in
the mirror take a photo of it post it on
your story tag me so i can cheer for you
and start to notice what happens
something weird happens by day four when
you get out of bed you're gonna have
this weird feeling that you've never had
you're gonna feel
like you're looking forward to seeing
yourself in the mirror because something
weird happens when you
start to really be present with yourself
when you normally walk in the bathroom
and you ignore yourself
you're alone
i think a lot of us feel like we're
alone in our lives
when you start to see yourself
you literally
oh
hey
hi there mel robbins how you doing
you now
as you look forward oh hey girl how are
you doing hi mel robbins oh hey let's go
i believe in you gotta have a great day
it's almost like when your neighbor
waves to you you're seeing yourself you
know now that i've been doing this for a
year
i don't feel like i'm alone i feel like
i've got myself and i've got my own back
i feel like this person that i see in
the mirror
is the one person that's going to be
with me for my entire life so i better
cheer for her i better celebrate her i
better
encourage her
and love her and that's what you're
doing when you do this every morning to
yourself and there are mornings where i
stand in my underwear at my bathroom
stink and even i don't have a word to
say to myself
but i can always do this and it always
lifts my mood and
it is creating that deep connection
within me to myself and that's what
builds your confidence confidence is
being comfortable in your own skin
confidence is knowing that you have your
own back confidence is knowing that you
can face something confidence is
believing in your ability
to
face or survive or try something and
be better
and confidence is being willing to try
and all of those things happen when you
raise your hand every single morning the
second thing that you should do is um
you got to be honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not
taking action in those areas
the lack of action says to your brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what i want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and i want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy
and that is a whole body of research
that says when you act like the person
you want to become it's the most
powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh
talk therapy because the action proves
to your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are and rule number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
stop victimizing yourself
i love myself because i feel comfortable
in my own skin i love myself everybody
because i don't label myself as a bad or
selfish or broken or whatever person
i just encourage myself i give myself
compassion and i work hard
every
day
to maintain that kind of relationship
with myself
i have truly stopped victimizing myself
and i have empowered myself by
encouraging and being compassionate with
myself
and you're meant to feel this way about
yourself too
this is how you're meant to feel you're
you're meant to feel comfortable in your
own skin you're meant to feel proud of
yourself you're meant to feel celebrated
and encouraged by yourself and look
i still don't live on the right street i
still don't belong to that country club
i can't go back and redo my college and
my law school years
but
here's what i can tell you
you can break the habit of beating
yourself up over the past
you can break the habit of constantly
victimizing and bashing yourself you can
break the habit of labeling yourself
with these horrible labels and indicting
yourself
by
saying you are this way
no the behavior that you engaged in may
have sucked back then but you don't suck
you're just a human being and you're
figuring things out and now that you
know
what you need to do better you can do
better
i'm going to teach you a mindset hack
that if you can learn to apply will help
you
eliminate your self-doubt your fears
your insecurities and step forward
confidently into whatever situation you
get yourself into and it's this
you teach yourself that you can learn
anything
you can learn anything you may not have
the answers right now you may not know
how to do the crazy thing that you want
to do you've got big goals big big
dreams big ambitions you want to do
something big that's why you're watching
this channel right you're part of
believe nation you want to do something
big with your life i love it you don't
know how to do it
you teach yourself i can learn
anything
because what we often
struggle with is
you want to do something you know you
can't do it yet and then you associate
with that i suck
i can't do something so i suck
and that
attack
on your self-worth on your
self-confidence on your self-esteem
prevents you from actually going off and
creating something amazing right i think
i think you're a genius i think you have
michael jordan level talent at something
i believe that i don't just say it in
videos i believe that that's true
so whatever you're stuck on
instead of making yourself feel like you
suck that you're not good enough that
you're not capable of it
understand that it's just a skill set
that's missing the difference between
where you're at right now and where you
want to be
is the skills that you acquire and then
the action that you're taking
you're willing to take action
problem is you probably don't have the
skills yet to be where you want to be
that's okay
you tell yourself i can learn anything
learning becomes a superpower i had a
guy on my instagram live not that long
ago
and
he was talking about becoming a digital
marketer and he was asking me
what
place do i sign up for a degree for
digital marketing and is it worth
getting the degree for digital marketing
because i want to i want to be a digital
marketer i want to sell my digital
marketing services to entrepreneurs
there are some fields where having a
degree is really important
digital marketing is not one of them
going to i don't even know if you can
get that in university but going to take
somebody's digital marketing
certification
is not going to be helpful for you in
terms of getting new clients you might
learn some new skills that you can use
to get new clients but he was putting
too much stock in the paper his belief
was in the paper that because he was
going to get this certification that
says that he was a digital marketer that
that would help him get more clients
now if you're going to get
a law degree or an accounting degree or
something official you know
professionals then great yes you can't
become a lawyer without going to law
school right
but digital marketing
if they're teaching at a school it's
already outdated digital marketing is
changing on the fly i look at what i'm
doing on my youtube channel
if i was to teach a course at a youtube
conference a year ago it would be
different it's why in my youtube growth
bootcamp i update it constantly with the
new things that i'm learning because it
changed from one year ago textbooks are
written like two three four sometimes
five six longer years ago
so apply to digital marketing it's
already out of date
but the problem with the guy who called
into my ig live was his faith his trust
was in the paper that having the paper
having a degree would help him get
credibility and close clients
his trust your trust your faith needs to
be in yourself
needs to be in you and your ability to
learn not in your abilities that you
have right now because you don't have
the abilities yet to do the thing that
you want to do you're not capable yet if
you were capable you would have done it
you're not ready yet that's okay but
you're able to learn you
you
you can learn anything
so whenever you're in fear and
insecurity in doubt you're not sure what
to do don't take it personally don't say
i suck as a human because i don't have
this skill set you can learn anything
remind yourself of it and then you need
to create a customized program for you
you need to create your own university
your own learning program so that every
day you're slowly acquiring that skill
that knowledge said that you're missing
it's why i created the 254 series where
every day for 254 days you get a new
video on a topic
that if you want more confidence if you
want more self love you want more
motivation you want to be a writer we've
got lots of different topics there's
hopefully something there for you but
even though i mean i may not have made
it yet right i made a whole bunch and
they're free for you but if i didn't
make it you go make your own
my youtube channel is my own that every
day i want more belief in my life and so
i created the channels for that and
hopefully that spreads and you guys like
it you're getting more belief with every
video too but you need to create your
own program
every day whatever the skill set is that
you want to learn that is the only gap
between where you are and where you want
to be because you're willing to take
action you just don't have the skill
sets yet but you're willing to learn and
you're able to learn anything you can
learn anything that needs to be on loop
in your head i can learn anything i
don't know how to do it yet but i can
learn anything
and then apply it so every day what are
you going to be learning
every day what video you're going to
watch what book you're going to read
what podcast you're going to listen to
how are you going to learn who are you
going to reach out to who's done the
thing that you want to do and how can
you learn from them and apply it
every day
it's there's never been more information
out there there's never been more
thought leaders experts people who've
succeeded sharing their tips their
advice their knowledge their feedback
and you can start for free before you go
and hire somebody as a as a coach
or you drop thousands of dollars on
somebody's mastermind
consume their content for free youtube
videos are free
podcasts are free
buy their book it's gonna cost 20 bucks
25 bucks right invest small make sure
you're getting knowledge that helps
make sure you're getting knowledge that
when you apply it works and then you can
start spending more but you need to see
a return on investment for every dollar
you put in for all the mentors that you
pick your time and the money that you're
putting in
you're a genius i i and i you know a
little frustrated because i love you and
i want to see you win and i see so many
talented people and believe nation with
great ideas great ambition and great
heart great heart like you want to do
great things for the right reasons and
serve the world
you just haven't learned the skills yet
and so you remind yourself i can learn
anything
whatever problem in front of me right
now
i don't have the skill sets yet
then i
can learn
anything self-improvement is the answer
to whatever obstacle is staring you in
the face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and tony robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who at 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like jim rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six billion dollars
in annual revenue if tony robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world
why can't you the difference is he made
the investment to constantly improve
himself and you haven't yet at that
level so i look at my channel as an
example my youtube channel and i've
learned so much over the past number of
years
in confidence and growth and abilities
and skills by consuming the content
because i love the top 10 series and the
men to me series in the international
series i make them for me and then i
share them with you and thankfully you
guys like them too and i can build a
business off of it and keep pumping out
more content but it helps me i've grown
i've learned and one of the biggest
moments that helped me realize how much
i've learned is when i signed a
three-year deal with sage i was working
with stephen kelly who was the ceo and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my youtube channel
answering questions from people and i
was driving with my dad and i remember
him asking me how do you get the
confidence to be on
a call with stephen kelly and be seen as
his equal all the time and he wasn't
asking me to put me down he was asking
me in in genuine of he was so happy for
me that i was playing a bigger game
and it dawned on me that he was right
the evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the evidence of
five years ago would have felt less than
the evidence five years ago would have
said there's no way i'm capable of doing
that and then when i'd signed the deal i
felt like
it's great i love stephen he's amazing
but i feel like i'm hanging out with
oprah and kanye and steve jobs and bill
gates and these super successful people
and they're infiltrating my brain on a
daily basis right a daily basis three
videos every single day on this channel
and so bit by bit it pulls me up now i
recognize i still have a long way to go
i still have so much more to learn i
still need to believe in myself even
more and every time i consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are are
little tiny incremental parts of your
growth i couldn't point you to one point
in my past where i said that was the
moment that i changed that was the
moment that i had more confidence but as
i studied every day every day every day
i could look back three months six
months a year and say wow i've really
changed i've really grown i've really
learned a lot but in the daily from
today to yesterday i'd say i didn't grow
at all and so sometimes on your journeys
you're trying to learn and get better
you may feel like the growth is really
slow on a daily basis but if you keep
going you keep investing you keep
learning you keep seeking out mentors
you keep trying to get better and
improve not every day will be amazing
but if you try every day to get better
and learn i can guarantee you that in
three months six months one year when
you look back
of the person you've become compared to
what you are right now they'll be a big
change and that's because you continue
to invest in yourself so i'm going to
give you a three-step process to how to
create a customized program for you so
that you can become world-class at the
thing that you want to be class at step
one decide what you want to be world
class at you could be world class at a
lot of things with enough energy effort
wisdom porn in to you practice
repetition you can be world class at
something but what what like what in
your core what is the thing that you
need to be world class at what is the
burning desire in you that you say i
want to be
among the best in the world at
what
fill that in what do you want to be
world class at number two immerse
yourself in that environment the fastest
way to learn a language the fastest way
to learn japanese is not from a textbook
it's not from going to classes it's to
go to japan you need to immerse yourself
in the environment whatever the thing is
that you want to be great at the more
you are around it people who are doing
it people who are speaking it people who
are living it the more it will rub off
onto you and the faster it will rub off
onto you now it can be a physical
environment or it could also be from the
content that you're consuming i get it a
lot from my own youtube videos because i
feel like i'm around steve jobs and elon
musk and oprah winfrey every single day
and the more you immerse yourself in
that environment the more their mindset
the more their motivation the more their
confidence is going to stick with you to
help you go be world-class the thing
that you want to be great at and then
step number three is practice every
single day you need to practice every
single day it's not enough just to be
around it you need to practice you got
to do you want to be world class at
something right that requires daily
dedication the reason why i got better
at making my content my videos is i've
done 6 000 videos a thousand videos
aren't even public on my channel we've
thrown away more videos than most people
ever create on their channel and it's
not because i'm amazing go back like i
encourage you go back and look at my
first videos i sucked it was brutal it's
because i said i want to be great at
this thing and i surrendered myself with
people who could help push me and i
could learn from and then i practice
every single day the reason why i pass
people who are considered to be a lot
better than me at this is because i put
in my work because when people had a
hard time finding time to make one video
a week i was doing three a day
and if you take that same approach if
you take that same mindset of i'm just
gonna outwork everybody around me i'm
gonna outwork my competition when they
may have a hard time finding time to do
that thing that they need to get better
at once a week and you're doing it three
times a day you will blow past people
who are more naturally talented because
you have put in the work to get good at
your skill because you made it this far
in a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because
you are awesome to see my recent
interview with mel robbins one on one
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i hope your
business goes bankrupt evan evan you're
a terrible person i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way